I'm zine Baker I'm one of the editors on
thor ragnarok hello the goddess of death
is invaded as god
working with tanka was massively
entertaining he's just a very involved
and funny guy he's definitely hands-on
and we we spent a lot of hours getting
every frame just right but always fun
you're always coming into work and
you're coming home laughing either one
of my favorite scenes that I cut for the
movie was the apartment scene where they
go back to Val's apartment surprise
this would be such fun you want to try a
version with this line and you know
somebody might have cracked a good joke
here instead of over here so then you
you look at it in the context of the
whole movie and for times sake you know
you just kind of got a weed it down you
and I had a fight recently did I win
now I want these Li doesn't sound right
oh that's true I was surprised by the Li
way that you know the editors can have
and going through the movie scene my
scene and picking out well this would be
good for IMAX let's try this
in particular we wanted to really
showcase doors introduction to Sekar
with the the chair ride and accentuate
Thor's point of view which is pretty
trippy
[Music]